THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
WHEN PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS MOCKED
BY CANADIAN PRIME MINISTER
JUSTIN TRUDEAU THIS WEEK AT THE
NATO MEETING, OF COURSE OUR
PROCESS ATE IT UP.
SEE, WE ARE NOT RESPECTED IN THE
WORLD.
>> THEY WERE ESSENTIALLY
LAUGHING AT THE U.S. PRESIDENT
THERE.
THAT'S REMARKABLE BIT OF MAGIC
GETTING LEFT AN ENTIRE
CONTINENT.
THIS IS HOW THEY TALK ABOUT OUR
PRESIDENT.
>> WHEN PEOPLE ARE LAUGHING AT
YOU, THAT MEANS YOU ARE THE
JOKE, THE BRUNT OF A JOKE RIGHT
THERE.
>> THEY WERE JUST GOING TO BE --
>> WRONG.
WRONG, WRONG, WRONG.
>> Laura: I WONDER IF JUSTIN
IS STILL LAUGHING.
>> WE ARE COVERING THIS
BREAKING NEWS THAT THE AKKADIAN,
CANADIAN ECONOMY IS SHEDDING
MORE THAN 70,000 JOBS IN THE
MONTH OF NOVEMBER.
THIS IS THE LARGEST JUMP IN THE
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE WHEN YOU LOOK
AT SORT OF MONTHLY PERFORMANCES
SINCE 2009.
>> Laura: NOT DOING SO WHILE
THEY ARE IN CANADA.
WE WANT YOU TO DO BETTER BUT NO.
REMEMBER FINCH PRESIDENT
EMMANUEL MACRON WAS ALSO THERE
GIGGLING ALONGSIDE TRUDEAU
BUT PERHAPS HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
TAKING CARE OF BUSINESS AT HOME.
>> OF THE SITUATION IN FRANCE IS
UNSUSTAINABLE RADIO HAS ON
EMPLOYMENT AT NEARLY 9%.
HUGE UNFUNDED PENSION LIABILITY
PAIR THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
UNSUSTAINABLE.
>> OF COURSE BRITISH FROM
MR. BORIS JOHNSON HOSTED THE
NATO SOIREE AND WAS ALSO HAVING
A GOOD TIME.
TOO BAD THE SAME CANNOT BE SAID
FOR HIS OWN MIDDLE-CLASS.
THE U.K. ECONOMY IS IN THE WORST
SHAPES IN 2010 AND THINGS ARE IN
IT AND NOT ANY BETTER IN ITALY.
IT SCARES YESTERDAY'S HEADLINE.
ITALY'S ECONOMIC GROWTH OF SUCH
REMAIN WEAK IN NEAR TERM.
BUT GERMANY IS DOING BETTER,
RIGHT?
HERE'S WHAT THINGS LOOK LIKE
THEY ARE CREATED GERMAN ORDERS
RESUME.
CREDIT DEFYING HOPE FOR A
FACTORY REBOUND.
SO MAYBE THAT'S WHY ANNUAL
MERKEL ALSO LOOKS LIKE SHE'S SAT
ON A PINECONE ESPECIALLY WHEN
SHE'S NEXT TO TRUMP.
AFTER JAPAN THINKS AREN'T ANY
BETTER THERE.
JAPAN'S ECONOMIC TROUBLES
OFFERED A GLIMPSE OF A SOBERING
FUTURE.
I'M SHOWING YOU ALL OF THIS
BECAUSE EVERY DAY, AMERICAN
WORKERS SHOULD THINK THE GOOD
LORD THAT WE HAVE A PRESIDENT
WHO ACTUALLY GETS IT.
WE HAVE A TIGHT LABOR MARKET,
THAT MEANS WAGES ARE GOING UP.
WE HAVE MORE DEREGULATION THAT
FREES UP BUSINESSES TO GROW AND
HIGHER AND GIVES THEM A LOT OF
INCENTIVE.
WE HAVE LOWER TAXES, THAT MEANS
YOU KEEP MORE OF YOUR OWN MONEY
TO SPEND IT AS YOU SEE FIT.
THE DEMOCRATS, THEY DON'T TRUST
YOUR JUDGMENT.
IF THEY WANT MORE CONTROL OVER
ALMOST EVERY MAJOR DECISION YOU
MAKE.
THEY ARE ALSO OF COURSE TRYING
TO IMPEACH A PRESIDENT ON
NOTHING.
DURING ONE OF OUR GREATEST
ECONOMIES IN THE PAST
HALF-CENTURY.
>> 256,000 JOBS IN NOVEMBER.
THAT FLOWS AWAY EXPECTATIONS.
>> WE DON'T TAKE ANY GLEE IN
THIS AT ALL.
IT'S HEARTBREAKING.
BUT THE PRESIDENT GAVE US NO
CHOICE.
>> THIS IS THE BEST THING I'VE
EVER SEEN IN MY LIFE THAT YOU
CAN'T CONTRADICT THAT THESE ARE
THE BEST NUMBER WE'VE SEEN IN
OUR LIVES >> I SPEAK FOR MY
COLLEAGUES WHEN I SAY THAT WE DO
NOT TAKE THIS LIGHTLY.
>> EVERYONE SHOULD BE THRILLED
WITH THIS PRAISE TO GET TO GREAT
JOBS NUMBER HAS LET THIS MARKET
GO FROM STRONG TO BETTER.
>> WE DO NOT DELAY WHEN THE
INTEGRITY OF THE NEXT ELECTION
IS STILL AT RISK.
>> THIS IS A GOOD NUMBER FOR A
REELECTION.
>> Laura: WELL, THIS
DISSONANCE HERE --
--
AMAZING ECONOMIC NEWS AND GLUM,
MOROSE, HORRIFIED DEMOCRATS.
THEY WANT TO IMPEACH THIS
ECONOMY.
I'M GLAD THE WHITE HOUSE
DISMISSED DEMOCRATS AND
5:00 P.M. DEADLINE FOR
COOPERATING ON IMPEACHMENT
TODAY.
WHY DO I FIND IT HARD TO TAKE
PELOSI, NADLER, SHIFTS,
SERIOUSLY?
BECAUSE THEY ARE FUNDAMENTALLY
UNSERIOUS PEOPLE.
BLOOMBERG GAVE IT ALL UP
YESTERDAY IN AN INTERVIEW.
THEY KNOW THEY CAN'T WIN WITH
BIDEN IN THE GAME.
THAT'S WHY HE JUMPED IN.
THEY DON'T LIKE THEIR ENTIRE
2020 CAMPAIGN STRATEGY CONSISTS
OF ONE WORD, IMPEACHMENT.
THEY ARE JUST NOT SERIOUS ABOUT
WORKING ON IMPORTANT ISSUES THAT
COULD ACTUALLY IMPROVE YOUR
LIFE.
NOT USMCA, NOT PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS, NOT INFRASTRUCTURE,
DESPITE PELOSI'S CLAIMS TO THE
CONTRARY.
>> WE HAVE 275 BILLS THAT WE
MUST LEGISLATE, INVESTIGATE, AND
LITIGATE.
>> Laura: SHE SHOULD HAVE
ADDED REGURGITATE, OKAY?
IT'S THE SAME THING OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
IT'S A FARCE!
IN 2018, MODERATE DEMOCRATS
CAMPAIGNED ON THIS IDEA THAT
THEY WOULD WORK WITH THE
PRESIDENT ON KEY ISSUES BUT THEY
HAVE ONLY WORKED TO OUT HIM.
THEY SHOULD ALL BE TALKED OUT.
NONE OF THE 2020 DEMOCRATS ARGUE
THAT THEY CAN DO A BETTER JOB ON
THE ECONOMY.
THEY CAN'T.
THEY DON'T EVEN REALLY TRY
ANYMORE.
WHEN THEY ARE NOT PUSHING A
TOTALLY BASELESS IMPEACHMENT,
THEY ARE CATERING TO GROUPS LIKE
PLANNED PARENTHOOD, THE NEA,
CARE, AND OF COURSE THE E.U. WHO
BY THE WAY LOVES THEM BECAUSE
THE E.U. CAN PLAY THEM.
THIS HAS BEEN A PHENOMENAL WEEK
FOR THE PRESIDENT AND FOR THE
COUNTRY.
HE WAS DERIDED BY THE ELITES ON
THE INTERNATIONAL STAGE AND BY
ACADEMICS ON THE DOMESTIC STAGE
AND HE ENDED IT WITH A SAKO
ECONOMIC REPORT THAT IS THE ENVY
OF THE WORLD.
THE DEMOCRATS AREN'T MAD BECAUSE
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS POLICIES
ARE WORKING.
THEY ARE LEAVING BECAUSE THEY
ARE.
I'M NOT SAD FOR THEM AND OUR
CARNIVAL ACT OF A PARTY BUT FOR
THE REST OF US, WE ARE TO KEEP
WORKING HARD AND PLAYING HARD.
WE ARE GOING TO BE COUNTING OUR
BLESSINGS AND STAYING FOCUSED ON